welcome to the NewsHour we begin in
Sudan where in a few hours time the
week-long humanitarian ceasefire is set
to expire but despite the truce
explosions and gunshots have again rung
out in the capital Khartoum the fighting
between the Army and the paramilitary
rapid support forces hasn't stopped
dozens of breaches were reported during
the past week and more than 860
civilians have been killed so far
humanitarian agencies say there must be
a pause in fighting to let Aid reach
those who desperately need it the UN
walls at half of Sudan's population
needs humanitarian assistance the
warring sides say that they're willing
to discuss extending the truce but
according to Saudi and the U.S mediators
both the Army and the rsf are readying
for further escalation Hippa Morgan
joins us now from OnDemand I mean hibber
we're just a few hours away from that
ceasefire ending I mean what news are
you hearing about the possibility of it
even being extended at all
well both sides the rapid support forces
on Saturday said that it was ready to
extend the ceasefire as per the
agreements uh signed which says that
they should be a 48-hour notification
given to the mediators so the rapid
support forces released a press
statement saying that it is ready to
extend the ceasefire that was signed in
the Saudi city of Jeddah now this
special Envoy of the head of the army
also told Al Jazeera just a few minutes
ago that the Army is also willing to
extend for humanitarian purposes and
that was the whole reason why that
ceasefire was signed between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army in
the first place to open humanitarian
corridors for a to be able to reach the
million square trapped not just in the
capital Khartoum but other parts of the
country where there is fighting it is
worth noting though that both Saudi
Arabia and the United States has
described the ceasefire as imperfect
with violations happening from both
sides such as Army launching airstrikes
despite the fact that that is banned or
not allowed expertise agreement as a
ceasefire agreement and the use of heavy
artillery by the rapid support forces
and the continuing of the occupation of
hospitals vital facilities like water
plants and power plants by the rapid
support forces so that ceasefire which
both sides describe as imperfect is now
being discussed again in the Saudi city
of Jeddah for possible extension for
more humanitarian corridors to open for
a to reach those who are trapped in the
capital and other parts of the country
and of course many of the public as you
suggest are stuck indoors waiting for
that respite that ceasefire so they can
go and find Aid in the past seven days
we've talked about Aid trying to get in
I mean what's your assessment of what
was allowed in if anything was at all
labor
well we spoke to several eight
organizations and asked them were they
able to move around have they been able
to distribute humanitarian assistance to
those in need while some organizations
said that yes they were able to they say
that's not the target figure that they
were that they wanted to reach uh and
with humanitarian aid for example the
world food program began distribution
just two days ago here in umduman and
other parts of other parts of Sudan but
they say that they're trying to reach
half a million people and they've not
been able to do that especially in the
northern part of the capital heartum
where there's been intense fighting
between the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army now it's worth noting that
every single day for the past seven days
there's been some kind of explosion
there's been some kind of airstrike
that's been gunfire heard in parts of
the capital and in the city of
old-fashioned in North Darfur the
humanitarian situation continues to
deteriorate because of ongoing fighting
for four days now between the rapid
support forces and the Sudanese Army so
many of those who we spoke to say that
they've not been able to get
humanitarian assistance that medical
assistance something that is in dire
need for many people here because of
hospitals being affected by the fighting
has not been able to reach many here in
the capital of and in the western region
of Darfur many people say that the
ceasefire just gave an extension of a
chance for the rapid support forces to
continue their expansion in areas where
there have been civilians who've been
forced to leave their homes to be
occupied by the rapid support forces
others say that the Sudanese Army also
continued with its abstract so they feel
that the ceasefire has not been able to
achieve its aim of ending the fighting
between the rapid support forces or and
the Sudanese army or at least halting it
and delivering humanitarian Aid to those
in need Google continue to monitor
events as we're closer to that deadline
for the moment hibber Morgan there for
us in omdomen thank you